now here on swipe we're often talking
about the ways that technology
positively influences our lives
sometimes we might even take it for
granted a little bit I've been to visit
a Children's Hospice in Middlesex where
one small charity is making a big impact
with some special technology life lights
is a unique charity and our aim is to
enhance the lives of children with
disabilities and terminal illnesses in
hospices in every hospice across the
British Isles what we're trying to do
for the children is to give them
technologies which are going to make a
difference to them we're giving them
things that whatever their abilities
they're going to be able to use so
whether it's communicating through a
special app on an iPad or being able to
kick up leaves on a magic carpet
or play music with a sound man you very
much likes any kind of technology but
particularly stuff that she gets an
immediate response from if it's
something that she gets frustrated with
that's not great because Sophie's oxygen
levels drop quite considerably when
she's stressed when she's upset so
anything that's accessible and easy to
use is brilliant for her we have a good
understanding of what tech is coming to
market and we keep a keen eye on that
consumer tech to see what can be
modified and adapted so we can use an
eye tracker to enable someone to use
their eyes to interact with it we can
use touchscreen or we can use motion
control with someone actually
interacting on the floor it's really
exciting to see her using the enormous
brain I know that she has because she's
you know as capable as any other child
in many many sense and many other senses
but it's great that there's something
that she can access the same with other
children basically when we actually get
to the hospital after having raised all
this money done all the research bought
the best technologies to them and then
to see a young person be able to draw a
picture on a screen with their eyes for
the first time or to watch them use an
iPad and talk to their parents tell them
that they love them maybe for the first
time that is absolutely magical for us
and to see the parents faces as well and
the care staff that is just the best job
in the world I think